all right Lena is with us and Florida hi
Elena how are you
hi Bailey I'm good thank you for taking
my call sure sure so I worked as an HR
manager for about four years with a
company but they actually shut down in
July due to bankruptcy so about two
weeks ago I got offered a new work
opportunity in a new city it was sixty
thousand a year and in the same field
Human Resources but when I my first day
when I walked into the hospital the
manager that the guy was supposed to be
my manager he actually was in the
process of resigning because the state
had the week prior ordered that hospital
to shut down so I pretty much walked
into a jobless job so to move out here
at this time $1,100 a month least my
monthly bills are about maybe eight
hundred with car insurance car no phone
bills food and I'm about twenty thousand
dollars in debt so I'm fin trying to
budget myself but I think my only option
I announced about the bankruptcy she's
talking I help you you don't get out of
paying rent in bankruptcy you either pay
the rent or you don't get to stay in any
form of bankruptcy and you still have to
pay your money you still have to eat
bankruptcy does not create an income you
don't have a you don't have a debt
problem you have an income problem okay
because they take the twenty thousand
dollars worth of bills whatever that is
and just throw it in the trash let's not
worry about that today today you just
need to eat and get this rent paid or
get out of this lease have you talked to
your landlord about what it you know
about what happened and how can I get
out of this um yeah but I have to pay
about to thousands of cancel the lease
you know he did apologize but that's my
only option and how much as time is left
on the lease ends in April April first
okay so about six months all right and
so have you found any
work at all well I think within the past
week I've applied for about a hundred
places but I haven't received any calls
back so just waiting on that filling out
applications doesn't get you a job okay
that's not gonna work all right so we
have one of our MC personalities is a
guy named Ken Coleman and Ken
specializes in helping people not only
get jobs but get jobs that they love his
number one best-selling book is the
proximity principle and it talks about
the proven strategy that will lead you
to the career you love and also I want
you I'm gonna send you a copy this book
as a gift okay because what you need is
income income is your problem and so I
want you to when you hang up I want you
to do two things
one is I want you to call three pizza
places and I want you to be delivering
pizza by nightfall okay someone will
hire you on the spot you have a car
right yeah okay so you cuz you're you're
scared aren't you yeah maybe maybe I
would be you have no money coming in
right yeah none at all
do you have any money about $500 yeah I
would be scared what you gonna do when
that money's gone I'm not trying to
scare you I just been trying to you know
if I'm in your shoes I'm trying to think
how I would feel and so yeah I'd be
delivering pizzas cleaning houses
walking dogs driving uber by the end of
the day to get something coming in get
me you know a couple thousand bucks a
month coming in to at least be able to
eat and maybe start to scratch up to two
thousand to get out of this lease and
decide what you're gonna do where is
your family in New York okay is that
where you moved from to take this job
okay so you were already in Florida yeah
okay all right I'm gonna send you a copy
the proximity principle the first thing
I want you to do is is get on the phone
and talk to pizza places maid services
uber whatever you got to and let's get
some money coming in this week right now
ready
go the second thing I want you do is I
want you to go to Ken Coleman calm the
Ken Coleman show calm and I want you to
download his to PDFs they're completely
free and you need free stuff right now
and they talk about how to get a how to
get an application how to get connection
and how to fix your resume and how to
nail the interview because you're the
way you're doing these applications is
not gonna work so you hold on and I'll
have Kelly pick up will send you a copy
of proximity principle let's get you
some income coming in and that's gonna
solve a whole bunch of your problems